Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P. We have
a longtime racist caller named Troy who calls
in and he is parroting some of the same racist
talk about Catanese Brown Jackson, including
that she is not really a judge now at at the top
of the show, we already looked by the standards
set by the current nine Supreme Court justices.
Katagiri Brown Jackson is more qualified, more
qualified, but Troy doesn't care. No, there's
something about her. She's not a real judge.
Speaker 4: There is no doubt that the Joe
Biden nominee for the Supreme Court in
Brown Jackson is a joke and a disgrace.
Speaker 1: And of course, the constant, you
know, mispronunciation of her first name,
I think is part of this entire package.
Speaker 4: She's an activist, not a real judge.
And I hope the Republicans continue. To bash, this
woman humiliated, this woman, expose this from
the community's Jackson is.
And they need to do the same thing,
Speaker 1: is he saying, Kanena,
Speaker 4: Liberal Democrats, these
Republicans need to do the same exact thing.
What they do? I can't count them all.
And what they did back in the day
to Clarence Thomas, Jackson Browne or whatever.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So anyway, getting the name wrong
in the whatever her name is and she's not a real
judge, this is a pretty common racist trope. And
you all know that I am very, very careful about
calling things or people racist on this show.
This caller Troy has like a five year history of
calling in and making overtly racist comments,
and that's an important context to understand this
idea of being a real judge. I had an experience
with this idea, as applied to a two to a black
person. Back when I worked at Circuit City,
many of you remember when I was in high
school and at the very start of college,
I worked at Circuit City selling laptops. It was
quite a job and I learned a lot of things there,
including how to relate to people in so many
different things. But I also saw some really ugly
racism and xenophobia firsthand. We had a manager
at one point, a Jamaican American guy named
Lennox, one of the nicest guys. And he was he
was the manager. He was the manager of the store.
And there was this incident where the
store would close at 9:30 and at 9:30 to
a customer walked in through the employee exit. So
like the front doors were already closed. And this
guy walks in at 9:30 two through the door. That's
there for us to leave. And he grabs a DVD and says
he wants to buy it. And of course, the sales
systems were all shut down. It's all you know,
they're done were closed that that's it. And
he insists that he wanted to buy this DVD.
And we explained to him, You know, sir, we're
closed that. That's just it. And he said,
get the manager and outcomes. Lennox and Lennox
says, Sir, we're closed. You know, the registers
are shut off. I couldn't. I just can't take your
money. You're going to have to come back tomorrow
or buy the things somewhere else. You know, I
think maybe Best Buy's open till 10 or whatever,
and the guy says, Let me see the real manager.
There's no way you're the manager. And of course,
it wasn't definitive that what he meant is
how could this young black guy be the manager?
But we all sort of looked at each other
like, it seems like this is what's going
on. And then eventually, you know, one of the
one of the big warehouse guys came out and
just escorted the guy out almost like security.
And this idea of the where's the real manager?
You're not a real judge. It's a common trope. And
quite frankly, it's sickening. On the bonus show,
today, we are going to talk about the Leah
Thomas swimming controversy. We are going to
discuss it. Washington, D.C. is suing Grubhub
for allegedly using deceptive trade practices,
and mortgage rates are surging faster than
expected. What will the impact be on real estate?
What will the impact be on people's rent when
people rent apartments? We will talk about all of
it on today's bonus show. You can sign up at Join
Packman dot com. You'll get instant access to the
bonus show. You'll get The Daily Show without
commercials. Six hours earlier than we make it
available publicly, and you'll get priority when
we do our David Pakman show viewer town halls, all
of those benefits and more. When you sign up at
Join Pasminco, I will see you on the bonus show.